Emma Watson getting real about her
surprise break from acting yeah I'm
studying the record straight in a new
interview with Financial Times the star
explains why she made the decision to
step away quote I wasn't very happy if
I'm being honest I think I felt a bit
caged this was a huge deal for me Emma's
last on screen role was in 2018. Greta
gerwig's Little Women bath insisted we
not tell her because she didn't want to
ruin Amy's trip
and since she stayed out of the
spotlight the reason she felt she didn't
have much control over her career it was
very difficult to be the face and the
spokesperson for things where I didn't
get to be involved in the process I was
held accountable in a way that I began
to find really frustrating because I
didn't have a voice I didn't have a say
this isn't the first time it was taken
an acting Hiatus I want to be really
picky about the parts that I chose to
play the Harry Potter actress took time
off to study at Brown University back in
2009 at the time telling E.T it wasn't a
forever goodbye I've been working
solidly since I was like nine years old
and I want to have a bit of a break and
I want to go and study properly rather
than try and do everything and not do
anything properly if that makes sense so
I'm gonna see how it goes you know
University there are long holidays and
stuff when I could easily schedule a
film if I wanted to so I'm going to keep
reading I'm reading a lot of scripts I'm
meeting a lot of different casting
agents and just you know seeing how it
goes and if there's something I really
want to do then I'll definitely do it
but it going to University doesn't mean
that I'm giving up acting but for fans
who think Emma's giving it all up again
she says returning to acting isn't
completely out of the picture I'm happy
to sit and wait for the next right thing
I love what I do I
incredibly blessed in my career so far
in the meantime Emma's focusing on a new
Venture the launch of Renee a gin brand
she's starting with her younger brother
Alex
she sells Financial Times getting
involved with the creative side of the
Gin has been fun because I have a voice
and I can bring everything that I've
learned to help I'm just loving being
involved with it yeah Emma's totally
loving putting her energy into something
new now that she's got a bit more free
time but hopefully fans won't have to
wait too long to see her back in front
of the camera
[Music]